تنضم الينا شبكه مراسلين من الجنوب دونيسك
امين درغامي ومن اكرامي
عامر ابدا معك تطورات الجبهه والروايه
الاوكرانيه في ما يتعلق بالهجمات والهجمات
المضاده
القتال الشرس مستمر على طول خطوط المواجهه
في اقليم تنباس وفيلوغاز يذكر طبعا بان
الرئيس الاوكراني نفسه كان قد وصف هذه
الجبهه بالاشرس في عموم اوكرانيا قياده
الاركان تحدثت اليوم عن تمكنها من صد عشره
محاولات تقدم للجيش الروسي في دونيس
وتحدثت عندما تكونها من تدميره رتل
للاليات العسكريه الروسيه في لوغاس
وتحديدا قربه همم قريه همم سيروتين همم
بالحديث ايضا عن لجانس عاد اليوم حاكم
لوكاس جلال للحديث عن التعزيزات التي تصل
والمستمره للجيش الروسي في هذه في هذه في
محاور لوغاز وان العديد من الالاف ربما من
القوات والجنود الروس الذين انسحبوا من
غير سوني يتم ارسالهم الى هذه المحاور
وتحديدا وفق حاكم لوكاس الاوكراني الذي
قال بان
هو المحور الرئيس الذي يتم ارسال اليه كل
هذه التعزيزات لان الروس كما يقول يدركون
بان هذا المحور اذا منهار فان الطريق
سيصبح مفتوحا امام الجيش الاوكراني
للسيطره على المدن الكبيره ونعي هنا طبعا
لسي شانس وسيفرودونيس وبالتالي معظم
التعزيزات الدفاعيه للجيش الروسي على هذا
المحور الحديث طبعا
مقاطعه ايضا كما ذكرنا الجيش همم
الاوكراني قال ابنه 10 محاولات لكن تبقى
وربما منذ اكثر من اسبوعين محورين بخمود
وافدي يبقى هما المحورين الاشرس من حيث
المعارك بالنسبه لمخموت لا يوجد تقدم
للقوات الروسيه هناك ربما الكلى الجيشين
يحافظ على مواقع على الرغم من القصف
الشديد والمعارك الشرسه المستمره هناك
مصادر هناك تحدث لنا عن ان اعداد كبيره من
قوات راجنر قتلت في هذه المنطقه الحرام صح
وصفها بين الجيش وانا هو بصعوبه وشراسه
المعارك يصعب علي احد سحب هذه الجثه الجثث
الكثيره لقوات فاجنر في هذا المحور امين
ماذا تقول السلطات الروسيه والمواليه لها
عن تطور الجبهات ايضا من الجهه التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا
نعم جلال لو نبدا من تصريح الذي صدر قبل
قليل فقط عن الاداره العسكريه والمدنيه
الروسيه في خرسون في عفو رجل التي اعلنت
عن همم قصف القوات الاوكرانيه لمدينه هذه
المدينه التي تقع فيها محطه زباروجيا
النوويه وقال عضو هذه الاداره الروسيه
الاوكرانيه استهدفت
بنحو كيلومتر واحد فقط عن عن محطه زباروجه
النوويه وذلك طبعا بعد همم يوم فقط من
الاتهام الذي وجهته روسيا الى اوكرانيا
باستهداف المحطه همم خلال يومين متتاليين
همم الاداره ايضا الروسيه هناك قالت بان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زال تحشيت قواتها
باتجاه كل من جوليان طول وايضا هذه
المناطق في مقاطعه زبوجيا لا تبعوت كثيرا
عن مدينه ميليتو بول التي سيطر عليها
الجيش الروسي منذ بدايه هذه الحرب هناك
اتهامات للجانب الاوكراني بانه يحاول بحسب
طبعا همم التصريحات الروسيه يحاول فتح
جبهه جديده في مقاطعه زاباروجا وصولا الى
همم الى يعني سواحل البحر ازوف وتحديدا
الى برديس لقطعه الطريقه التي تعول عليه
روسيا كثيرا والذي يربط بين اراضيها همم
تحديدا همم مع همم يعني حدود مقاطعه
دونياس خصولا الى شبه جزيره القرم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اليوم قالت بانها احبطت
هجمات للقوات الاوكرانيه في هذا المحور
حيث نحن جنوب الدهنيه باتجاه بلده بابلوكا
التي كانت قد سيطرت عليها شكرا وقالت
بانها كبدت القوات الاوكرانيه اكثر من 70
همم عسكريه بين قتيل وجريح وتحدثت ايضا في
همم بشكل موازين عن همم صد هجمات اخرى في
كل من ليمان وايضا كوبيانسك في محور طبعا
مقاطعه لوغانسكو ايضا في المحور الشمالي
تحديدا في مقاطعه الخارجيه شكرا لكم امين
في دونيسك وعامر فيكراموس